le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
au côté des
Réunionnais l'île de la Réunion classé
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité pour
plus de 40 % de sa superficie regorge de
réserve naturelle unique au monde parmi
les sites les plus populaires il y a le
volcan c'est la star des sites visités à
la Réunion la route qui mène jusqu'au
volcan offre une grande diversité de
paysage de points de vue et d'air de
repos très fréquenté mais cette grande
fréquentation entraîne aussi des
dégradations alors comment protéger ces
lieux uniques tout en les partageant et
en gardant leur authenticité on en parle
maintenant dans lien
social à la Réunion 40 % du territoire
et 95 % de la forêt domaniale et la
propriété du conseil général c'est une
grande fierté pour le département mais
aussi une grande
responsabilité l'entretien de ces sites
demande beaucoup d'investissement et de
moyens humains pour que les réunionnais
et les touristes profitent au mieux de
ces lieux particuliers le Conseil
Général entreprend des actions pour les
améliorer il réaffirme son attachement à
valoriser les haut sous tous leurs
aspects économique social culturel
touristique mais aussi
naturel la préservation des espèces
remarquables de l'île doit se concilier
avec l'appropriation continue de site
par les
Réunionnais c'est ce double objectif que
le Conseil Général poursuit avec ses
partenaires au profit de la population
réunionnaise ce travail avec les
partenaires comme l'ONF porte ses fruits
car le taux de fréquentation augmente
chaque année un succès qui entraîne des
aménagements qu'il faut penser de
manière économique et écologique on est
dans une démarche de de modernisation et
d'offre
à la population
réunionnaise de d'offrees agréable
d'accueil sur ces sit qui sont plus de
130 aujourd'hui qui est géré par les
services du département avec notre
partenaire je dirais officiel qui est
l'Office National des Forêts ces actions
a pour but de de
préserver le côté naturel de ces de nos
forêts de de ces sites d'accueil de nos
sentiers pour que demain les réunionnés
et les touristes puissent bénéficier de
ce de ce panorama qui est l'ensemble de
de la forêt de laarine suite au
classement mondial à
l'Unesco de nos de nos ciercles de nos
remparts et du classement de nos forêts
en parc national aujourd'hui le le parc
national est un partenaire aussi
essentiel dans l'aménagement m de nos
forêts dans la valorisation et dans la
préservation de ces de ces sites et ces
aires d'accueil et c'est important
aujourd'hui que les réunionnés
s'approprient je dirais ces territoires
mais aussi qui le préserve et qu' le
valoris eux-mêmes il y a le côté
écotouristme qui est important
l'aménagement des sites d'accueil
l'entretien de nos sentiers apporte je
dirais euh du travail à notre jeunesse
plus de 700 jeunes aujourd'hui
travaillent sur l'entretien et la
préservation et la création de
sentier et justement ces sites pourront
demain être aussi mis en valeur
économiquement par les gens qui habitent
les qui habitent ces ces ces lieux ces
efforts et ses actions sur l'aménagement
des sites des haut font plaisir aux
visiteurs qu'ils soi réunionnés ou
d'ailleurs ils apprécient de pouvoir
profiter de ces sites sauvages avec des
aménagements adaptés et confortables
pouvant accueillir parents et enfants ou
je monte assez souvent bon la route
elle-même est très bien il y a pas de
souci je trouve que c'est il y a pas mal
d'arrêts
pour pour admirer la vue et cetera je
pense qu'au niveau facilité pour faire
piquenique en famille et cetera oui il y
en a à peu près partout c'est disimminé
partout je pense qu'il y a il y a la
place pour tout le monde main non
effectivement il y a toutes les
facilités nécessaires pour apprécier un
petit euh petit picnique en
famille côté amélioration je vois pas
vraiment parce que il faudrait pas trop
trop améliorer non plus parce qu'après
ça va
dépaysager c'est endroit un peu spécial
bah les points de vue bon il y en a il y
en a pas énormément par rapport au
relief géographique mais je pense qu'ils
sont bien placés toute façon ils sont
passés dans une
logique dans la logique du paysage
mais effectivement si on aurait si on
pouvait en en installer plus ça pourrait
être çaêtre positif de toute façon au
niveau des touristes et C dans le cadre
de leur politique environnementale l'ONF
et le Conseil Général s'emploi à offrir
au public des espaces naturels en
adéquation avec les attentes et
l'évolution de la société les 350 a
d'accueil aménagé très prisé du public
favorise une pratique répandue au sein
de la population qui est devenue une
véritable institution le piquenique à
l'image de pyon sec ces sites sont
devenus des lieux in contournable d'une
forme d'immersion dans un environnement
naturel et la route du volcan sera
bientôt aménagée en route
d'interprétation avec des points de vue
et des nouvelles aires de pique-nique
qui seront réalisés dès cette année et
jusqu'en
2016 le Conseil Général de la Réunion
vous a présenté lien social le Conseil
général au côté des
Réunionnais